The jogan Experience well that seems so
crazy to think there's not a list that's
why Jimmy Jimmy said he's a tin foil hat
guy there's a lady in jail for sex
trafficking to no to no one like there's
no one who's been arrested that she sex
traffic too that's what say well well
there's a list that's out who knows if
it's fake I don't know it could be a
fake list who
knows Chris Tucker's on that list and
they asked Chris Tucker on a podcast
what's up with you being on the list he
didn't do what Jimmy Kimmel said Jimmy
Kimmel said it's a fake list who cares
without that what that list says it's
fake right Chris Tucker goes yeah I did
I did go on that flight but we went to
Africa and I went with a bunch of
diplomats I didn't know who this [__]
Epstein guy was like Chris Tucker says
like I had no idea we were on this plane
we were going to Africa do some
diplomatic [__] and turns out he's a
pedophile I I didn't know well they
definitely got people connected to him
by using famous
people my point was my point was Chris
Tucker basically confirmed it confirmed
that the list was like legit cuz he's on
it right there's this dude that was
inviting me to this conference once and
he was like Kanye West is going to be
there I'm like oh Kanye West going to be
there next thing you know you're there
right and if you don't know who's there
and some do this was just a conference
it was like a Tech conference they
wanted me to come and talk about like
the influence of social media and
podcasting and [__] I like I talk about
that all the time what am I going to go
with it but point is they were trying to
lure me by saying that some famous dude
I know was going to be there so if you
hear like oh my God you know Richard
Dawkins is going to be there you think
it's safe yeah all these famous people
are going to be there world leaders
going to be there what was Stephen
Hawkins doing that list so much Stephen
Hawkins was a freak he used to go to
strip clubs really yeah cuz he could
feel but he couldn't move you know who
told me about that Eric Weinstein Eric
to told Weinstein told me about that
back in the day he would go to like
swingers clubs he would lay there and
they all dry raate on him just because
it probably felt good and he can't he
can't move but he could feel he had Luke
Garrick's disease so his body just the
dicks still get hard though I bet I mean
he's not stupid he's smart as [__] he
just can't move it's crazy because why
like to go to the effort to Black maale
stepen Hawking well like you know how
easy that would be if like you really
really want to you wouldn't want to
Blackmail doing had a bunch of handlers
though but you know what I'm saying how
easy the guy's in a wheelchair he can't
even move you got put him in any
situation and what is he going to do say
stop stop like we're going to wheel you
in you're on this island now like no you
have to think of it in terms of a long
picture like what is the picture if you
have esteemed scientist Nobel laurates
Scholars all these different world
leaders Bankers famous singers famous
act actors they're all there so that's
the the way you get people to do it you
you invite people to this immense lavish
celebration that with intellectual world
leaders Geniuses and you think well how
could it be bad if all these Geniuses
are there yeah and then next thing you
know you're doing yo and you got some
girl from some Eastern BL country that's
rubbing your and you don't know that
she's 16 and she takes you in a room and
the room is filled with cameras
blackmail yeah yeah and I think it's all
about we're probably facing the effects
of that right now I bet there's
decisions that were made there's
influence that got moved around there's
there's people that support a certain
narrative because they were on that list
was it that what I was saying all day
today you has to I think everything
that's going on right now in the world
is linked to Jeffrey Epstein that's what
I think I think I think everything Trump
[__] everything everything everything
who's connected who like I don't know
yeah well you know all of it all of it I
met you we've discussed UFOs UFOs have
been around they've been talking about
them since Jesus left Chicago right but
the last three [__] years everybody's
seen [__] UFOs yeah how about that
Miami Miami come on the people for 40
years that's what you saw you didn't see
no [__] aliens but that's what
they're selling all now people from the
Navy it's a dist all of a sudden all
these Pilots yeah I was going here and
they were driving right next to me
waving at me really and now you decide
to [__] tell me this is what I think
this is what I think tell me the the
there's a lot of important people that
were on that list right right a lot from
all over uh the world right politics
Hollywood
Music you saw out there Chris Tucker
pretty much said it was real yep um not
that everybody on the list did [__] who
knows it would be easy to like you said
drag like if in the 90s or in the 2000s
if I if people would have liked my music
and I want to had a record deal thank
God nobody liked it and somebody said is
let's go to an island dog there's a
billionaire he's got a bunch of [__]
that were going to party I think I would
have
went you know what I mean then you go
you go talking to a scientist and then
you're like dude people brought their
kids they like no dude those are the
[__] like oh [__] I'd be on a [__]
i' be on a [__] kayak where's Miami
how far is Florida do you think [__] do
what do you think this UFO thing is what
do you think the UFO thing
I no no this is the point this is the
point my point is the people that are on
the list would rather like if they had a
choice you want to go to jail for this
[__] as a pedophile or would you rather
have World War III would you rather have
[__] Civil War would you rather have
a fake alien Invasion where every the
the world changes like the whole world
changes right away what would you go
would you rather go to guantan Mo Bay
would you rather go to prison or would
you rather have World War III Mad Max
Alien Invasion that's what I think World
War III would save them uh a alien
invasion would save them and a civil war
will save them so they want all that
[__] they want all that they want
complete chaos so they don't go to jail
that's what I think I don't like that
the list only released 300 people a lot
more than 300 people on that [__]
Island and I think they took the bottom
half like 300 people on that list I I
don't I guess I don't know the if the
the official list has been released has
it yeah no no who know who knows the
could be fake the list could be fake
they just releasing a list but they're
still covering up the [__] but but
but Chris Tucker he basically said he
didn't deny it he said yeah he said he
flew with Jeffrey ever to Africa but he
didn't say he went to the Island I think
the people that went to the island
that's where things get real weird but
you could go you go to the island and
not know either he also had a place in
Manhattan he was famous for having big
parties at this house in Manhattan that
he got from the guy who owned Victoria
Secrets the most expensive him guy gave
him this5 million mansion there was
other guys that were like these big
hedge fund guys that gave him like a
hundred million gave it to him and they
can't track why yeah nobody knows why he
was so powerful
also Trump's on the list but Trump was
like n we hitched a a ride to Trump
Towers what you got to look into what
you got to look into is jizan Maxwell
was his partner but jizan Maxwell's
father or what what the [__] jizan G gay
look into to her father Robert Maxwell
yeah all the answers are right there cuz
he was a
spy